nunca juzgues a un libro por su portada
en mi caso nunca juzgues a un software
por su hardware
de niña yo quería ser diseñadora porque
desde muy pequeña he tomado clases de
dibujo y siempre me gustaba hacerlo pero
conforme fui no y adquiriendo nuevos
conocimientos
la elección de mi carrera se volvió cada
vez más difícil pero si algo tenía muy
en claro es que yo quería hacer una
mujer que dejará huella
realmente la idea de ser ingeniero en
tecnologías nunca pasó por mi cabeza
porque no conocía ningún caso de una
mujer famosa en este ámbito porque
aunque existen pocos son los casos
realmente conocidos
se considera que las carreras
relacionadas con ciencia y tecnología
son las carreras del futuro porque son
agentes de cambio mejoran la calidad de
vida sin embargo el porcentaje de
mujeres inscritas en estas carreras son
del 35 por ciento aproximadamente
y yo no caí en cuenta de por qué si a
todos nos gusta la tecnología ponga
somos las mujeres que nos dedicamos a
esto
cuesta creerlo pero es una idea que ya
tenemos casi desde que nacemos a las
niñas nos educan con la idea de que nos
que nos desenvolvemos mejor con el rol
femenino en cuanto a las carreras que si
cuidamos a personas en medicina que si
estamos en contacto con las personas
sociales sin embargo no nos van
alentando a que tuvimos una carrera
técnica
cuando yo quería elegir carreras
tenía ambas partes mi mamá es abogada
mi papá es informático
y yo tenía un poquito de ambos
al momento de entrar a la carrera me
enfrenté a muchos comentarios
no pareces ingeniera
de verdad estuviese en esta facultad
hay entonces muy bonito pero
y por atrás
entonces
les cuento a ustedes como se supone que
debe lucir una ingeniera
qué pasa cuando yo les digo piensen en
un abogado
ponga él en su mente o sea imagínense un
abogado
ahora vence a un médico
hoy imagínense aún hay 3
a una bailarina con modelo
todas estas características que ustedes
empiezan a pensar son de personas
públicas limpias que se ven bonitas
sin embargo qué pasa cuando pensamos en
un informático o en alguien relacionado
con el área de tecnología
son personas raras son frikis
son personas informales y desde
alineadas de verdad además de que todos
los que nos dedicamos de esta área
captamos con una idea de que todos los
hacker
si lamento decirles que no todos nos
dedicamos a esos mitos arreglamos
computadoras todo el tiempo y teléfonos
lo lamento
y fue entonces
que algo en annette pasó
el problema de todas estas ideas cuando
te las llegas a creer que las tomas como
tuyas
y saben quién está en vuestras ideas
entonces decidí cambiar mi forma de
decirme de actuar porque estaba en un
mundo de hombres
es curioso porque en algún momento
considera estudiar ciencia política y me
decían no vale la que la política de
vida para una mujer está difícil y donde
terminé viviendo en un mundo totalmente
lleno de hombres fueron a contender pero
en mi salón nada más somos tres o
cuadras
a veces por materia nada más hay una
entonces puedes empezar a cambiar
y no todo es malo o sea realmente lo que
debes de tomar en cuenta es que si vas a
efectuar un cambio
lejos de tomar el cambio como negativo
tomes algo positivo de lo que te está
pasando no las horas extra que pude
dormir gracias al no tener que llegar a
arreglar a la universidad
y digo horas extras porque realmente son
minutos oa veces ni siquiera duermes y
entonces por eso entender por qué estas
personas llegan a hacer desaliñadas o
informales por ciento que arrestados son
sumamente demandantes
pago noche tras noche un programa bueno
en mica y pica línea por línea hasta que
encuentras un minúsculo error
pero este minúsculo error no te deja
dormir
la verdad es que pensé mil veces en
desistir y siempre que llegaba a ver
ropa en ellos
así que la llamada o las videollamadas
gracias a la tecnología me decían sabes
que no es tranquilo nada de que texas
para atrás no vas con todo porque vamos
a demostrar que las mujeres y podemos
bueno este era el comentario de mi mamá
y el de mi papá de no no no yo no tengo
que así
tú puedes con esto y más
una buena entonces
si pensamos en belleza a las mujeres
desde el principio nos surge una lista
enorme de devotos físicos
que debe tener una mujer para ser
considerada atractiva o bella sin
embargo no nos damos cuenta que la
belleza de la mujer radica en sus puntos
sus miedos hasta sus defectos y entonces
es aquí cuando nos damos cuenta que la
belleza no está peleada con la
inteligencia
además
la inteligencia en cuenta con diversas
matices y según los expertos existen 12
tipos de inteligencia
o sea tú no puedes juzgar que eres malo
en matemáticas pero tienes un gusto por
la música y es muy bueno no todos
estamos hechos para lo mismo y son esas
diferencias las que nos hacen ser ricos
como personas como seres humanos
si pensamos en mujeres tecnología y el
mundo actual viene a nuestra mente la
idea de que las mujeres más no
compartimos fotos de nosotras las redes
sociales y los mercados a nuestras mamás
limpias mandando cadenitas y jugando
jueguitos
no
pero no es así realmente el compacto de
la mujer actual con la tecnología no son
sólo las redes sociales
yo también pero no porque alguien me
dijera que debía hacerlo realmente y
también porque vi en el cambio una
oportunidad de mejorar todo
algunos hablan de recuerdo morir no
entonces tomé lo mejor de todo lo que
les pasa
por mi crítica vamos a ver de todas
si no es bueno ni malo ni peor solamente
somos diferentes rompamos con esos
estereotipos
hombres
me di cuenta que realmente no podemos
dejar al lado de los hombres
más hombres y deje de lado a las niñas
también medianos oye no sé entonces
físico vivir con tanto hombre no al
actuar en que ellos tienen otro punto de
vista que las mujeres requerimos y
viceversa igual un habla mis compañeros
hoy eres la única niña que conozco tengo
mi movimiento
y ahí vemos que todos necesitamos ambas
partes
somos complementos
no un hombre va más arriba que lo vamos
a la en colaboración
ante lo que te sucede sólo hay dos
opciones
la primera
o buscas una solución al problema en
caso de que la tenga o la segunda dejas
que todo fluya si es que no hay si ya no
puedes hacer nada deja que apoyar las
cosas solitas se van acomodando
toma lo mejor de la crítica
y no pienses en cosas negativas porque
va a ser lo único que termines atrayendo
como mujer te vivo
creen que con tanta muerte que el mundo
no puede evitar hacer la misma
que la niña
[Aplausos]